this whole week has been nothing less
than a fairy tale come true last year at
this time having a secret security
clearance I was writing instruction
manuals for the communication systems
aboard Air Force One and it turns out
Harrison Ford got it wrong the facts and
the phone lines to the White House are
actually not separate I probably
shouldn't have disclosed that but they
laid me off so what the hell
and over the next six months I finished
moonflower thinking I kid you not the
whole time I was on a fool's errand and
should concentrate on getting another
job which has been a struggle in this
economy so of all of the gifts bestowed
by the nickel committee the warmth and
support and friendship and guidance
given in such lavish abundance
validation to me has been the most
poignant and regenerative the
benevolence and generosity shodhan by
the Academy has moved and will continue
to move my heart forever thank you Greg
and Joan in Bryan and Eva Marie and
every single member of the fellowship
committee in the Academy for
transforming my life so magically thank
you